i mean the last six months have been
really tough it's a decision no
restaurant owner wants to make after 14
years we decide to close raymie mosca
says he can't find enough staff to keep
the doors open at me peru it's hard
we did our best we put our best effort
very challenging for a small business
trying to hire people right now he says
other companies are paying higher wages
and offering benefits something he can't
compete with just finding staff was very
very hard victoria martinez owns sunset
montessori school she is also having a
hard time maybe people save money and
are not ready to go back to work
others are having a change of heart like
i've done this my whole life maybe i
want to try something different unlv
economic professor stephen miller says
it is a changing economy i think we're
seeing restructuring in the labor market
he says smaller businesses are not able
to keep up with what some other
businesses are offering it's not a
problem if you have the necessary profit
margin that allows you to
to offer a few more benefits or to pay a
higher wage that that's what's happening
mosca says he hopes to reopen one day
meanwhile his customers were saddened to
hear the news pretty sad to see local
businesses struggling through the
pandemic
so yeah we'll enjoy this last meal